when did we know that privatizing the
Probation Service which supervises
offenders was a catastrophic ly bad idea
was it when Justice Secretary Chris
Grayling first ignored internal
government documents warning it had a
very high chance of putting the public
at risk or was it when the chief
inspector issued a damning report
eviscerating the changes a warning that
private companies were supervising 40%
of their offenders by telephone instead
of face to face meetings was it when the
taxpayer had to bail out the private
companies running this essential public
service to the tune of 500 million
pounds or was it when it emerged the
number of offenders were called to
prison for breaching license conditions
without finally 50% this is yet another
example of how this government's
determination to put public services at
the mercy of the market is costing us
more while making us less safe they have
rightly but very belatedly announced
they'll take probation back into public
ownership but this is more than a latest
manifestation of failing Grayling this
is why the Tory obsession with
privatizing public services needs to
stop here do you know until the last few
centers we're back together again and of
course you're right and just touching
briefly on our first conversation about
jeremy carr a government that now wants
to look into TV production wasting 500
million pounds on this and there are
claims in some of the papers today and I
went to name a name says no problems
that they've lost people because killers
or people who went on to be killers were
allowed on the streets who shouldn't
have been because of it I mean that it
gets nothing gets more grave than that
however to now say that all
privatization is wrong is wrong because
some have worked and I just choose one
you're too young I sense you're too
young this side of the room gets it in
the old days when I talk about the
winter of discontent
[Laughter]
very briefly that the revolution in
telecoms in this country by
privatization has been fantastic my
colleagues on my left I doubt magic can
if you moved house you might have to
wait two weeks before it was called the
post office or whatever it was the GPO
could actually give you a phone that is
how backward this country are you write
about this yes you are
are you write about all privatization I
would argue you're not because of
examples such as telecoms we've all had
jobs and we all take responsibility if I
had a job where I lose half a billion
pounds which is what they've done and it
doesn't work I would be slaughtered this
grayling sits there oh yeah that's good
to see what he said it feels as if
you've been trailed Charisse like mr.
misfortune in the department transport
with the drones before that in the
Ministry of Justice with very
controversial cuts to legal aid with
their issues with the Probation Service
why do you think it is that this kind of
misfortune seems to follow me well it's
a challenging time for all of us in
government we have to deliver change we
have to tackle new issues like the
drones for example so it's a question of
getting on with the job and tackling the
problems that best you can but the end
of the day dealing with your financial
positions and also dealing with
particular challenges like the expanding
demand on the railways you just got to
get on with the job and do your best
while the audience were watching him of
course what they don't how does somebody
like that 2012 the Ministry of Justice
before it was private before was
privatized did it did a survey of all 35
probation trusts and mark them all
excellent we're all doing a credible
email and you know we're laughing here
but the serious point here is a lot of
people there are a quarter of a million
people under the the Probation Service
three times more than the amount of
people that are in prison now those
people desperately need the help of an
efficient probation
and they're just not getting it this is
why just to come back to your question I
you brain I didn't say there's no room
for privatization but I said this
obsession with privatizing things in
this case in the face of all available
evidence
I mean it's railing ignored his own
departments Warner's it they predicted
it exactly exactly
this is this is an ideological of the
world and he decided I can make my name
I do it's an ideological obsession with
privatization even when it fails the
public and that's what we need to
challenge now what other public services
are being privatized even when it's not
in our best interest that's what I and
you know you might be right about
telecoms although I do remember recently
private network providers are being now
forced to compensate people when they
don't have their broadband speed
improved because they weren't willing to
do them there are lots of failings in
provision to rural services and you know
I think to portray all privatization is
working well actually if the danger is
ideological views then the danger is
ideological privatization and
ideological remash realization on both
ends of the spectrum where people rely
ideological there's a danger view isn't
it that everything that's at a public
service is is inefficient and if we put
it private it's gonna be efficient and
what efficient she actually means are
these private companies is low wages and
cutting staff and that's exactly what's
happened I really have in mind here is
the NHS because we all know that we live
in a climate where the NHS is vulnerable
you know these ideological forces of
privatization all honing our National
Health Service and we need to learn
these lessons before we end up because
the thing about the privation service is
as you were saying Carol this is so
serious this is people's lives at risk
this is the service that keeps the
public safe from people who want my work
as a probation officer so I again hard
to clear up social interest but I have
to tell you the idea I've talked to one
or two probation officers in the last
few weeks about what's been happening
and the idea that it's all come down to
how much profit we're making which is
what's happened that is what this is for
and it really is a terrible mistake and
it's ideal and grayling should have gone
you so what about no doubt what about
the the railways the National Grid where
where do we all miss it
I would fear if the railways were
realized I would fear that because III
just don't think that we bailed out by
us again this because you won't remember
the I don't know but I find it very
difficult to be persuaded the merits of
going back to the days of British Rail
that being said some of the rail
operators I won't name and are it's a
it's a racket and a certain kind of
pooling I don't know enough I don't know
a nice today I'm a bit like you know
pleasure good I don't know railways well
of course they would they don't you
don't have nationalize them hours you
just wait to the franchise's finishing
and you take the back so it doesn't cost
you anything yeah you said they take
them you would take it all back I think
the problem could be solved if we just
got Chris Grayling off the political
landscape about the privilege of the one
asking the question doesn't know I'm not
comfortable with the railways but I
don't know why you know whereas NHS your
point there absolutely and actually the
probation absolutely lots of the NHS
bits that are privatized no I mean for
instance you know you need a new knee
you can't get it through their help
they'll serve isn't good enough so
actually though they'll pay for probably
maybe part of the problem is I remember
what how bad the rail service was
shouldn't be shouldn't be privatized
lack of national health services like I
think everything else I mean I'm not
ideologically obsessed with the
nationalization you that I think at the
moment we excuse so much in favor of
privatization that we don't consider
three national Eisley when it might be
in our interest so I would like us take
an evidence-based approach to each
sector and work out whether we gave
that's what his department said to him
let's test this in one area and see if
it works
it was the 35 probation trusts were
rated as excellent and he messed them up
Wow it is extraordinary carried on and
what it does again speak to is that
these are the people who so often
lecture us as to how we should be living
our lives how we should be doing this
what TV we're allowed and they come
see what they face that's my question
because it feels like there's no account
this is another catastrophic error by
him another flaw in their whole
obsession privatization and it's gonna
be business as usual from